merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rtl
france à leur prime d'environ 100 euros
pour la pénibilité de votre travail
qu'est ce que vous en dites
c'est un premier pas on l'aurait que
jamais depuis 20 ans on attendait une
revalorisation de leurs deux nuits
depuis cinq ans un statut de travailleur
données ont été mis en place mais une
copie totalement vide
alors c'est un premier pas bien loin de
ce qu'on attendait la part du ministre
de l'intérieur
puisqu'une enveloppe de 37 millions
d'euros était demandée pour doubler ses
ordres de nuit qui sont aujourd'hui de
97 centimes
donc 10 millions on n'y est pas mais
c'est un premier pas on en attend un
geste supplémentaire n'a pas vu de la
part du chef de l'état et du premier
ministre
alors vous n'êtes plus vraiment d'accord
avec votre syndicat initial n'était
gepex il ne vous soutiennent pas dans
vos revendications
hormis un syndicat qui se bat et qui a
obtenu
d'ailleurs il faut le dire le statut de
travailleur de nuit les policiers la
nuit c'est ce qui est une très bonne
chose et on peut les en remercier la
seule difficulté c'est qu'ils se sont
tellement coupé du terrain aujourd'hui
que les nuiteux ne se reconnaissent plus
dans un syndicat qui peut se satisfaire
que de non pas 100 euros comme je
l'entends dire ce qui aussi ont réuni 10
millions d'euros / seize mille policiers
ça fait bien moins ça fait une
cinquantaine d'euros bruts qui en plus
concernés une indemnité qui ne sera pas
calculé pour la retraite on 6e se
satisfont de sa très bien mais ils n'ont
pas entendu les nuiteux syndiqués chez
eux chez eux
raison pour laquelle le secrétaire
général d'option lui et moi même avons
remis notre timbre aujourd'hui à unité
police parce qu'on ne se reconnaît pas
du tout ils nous écoutent pas il nous
entend pas au même titre que nos
politiques
avez vous l'impression en tout cas le
gouvernement prend un petit peu plus
conscience de voir difficulté c'est en
tout cas le message qu'elle essaye de
faire passer actuellement
oui et pour cause depuis automne 2016 il
ya une grande profonde de la police
nationale en particulier la nuit
vous avez eu l'occasion de le voir ces
dernières années des miennes
manifestation
rassemblement des gelures aux deux tons
de gris de sous les fenêtres des préfets
c'est bien parce qu'il ya un problème en
particulier la nuit ce qu'il faut être
conscient c'est qu'il ya de moins en
moins de policiers la nuit pour assurer
la tranquillité en tout cas des français
son territoire on est seize mille
nuiteux en france
seize mille 8e qui assureront la
sécurité avec une délinquance qui
augmente délinquance qui augmente la
nuit de 5 % chaque année depuis 3 4 ans
face à ça on a des policiers qui ne sont
plus du tout volontaire à la nuit et
pour cause travailler pour 8 euros la
nuit il prend tous les risques et toutes
les missions et tous les coups qu'on
prend ça devient particulièrement
difficile et quand je vous lis plus
aucun volontaire en france pour
travailler la nuit et pour redonner un
petit peu de crédit à la nuit rôles ont
redonné des envies aux policiers de
venir travailler la nuit c'est pas une
aide de 10 millions d'euros qui suffira
alors quelles sont les réponses
concrètes que vous attend dès maintenant
or maintenant on attendra de savoir
surtout la répartition qui va être faite
sur cette indemnité
puisque il semblerait que tous les
policiers me à la même enseigne
ceux qui effectueront 12h08 qui est un
cycle beaucoup plus pénible et en tout
cas beaucoup plus d'inconvénients sur
l'organisme aurait une indemnité plus
importante et certains risquent d'être
oubliés bien entendu dans la balance
puisque avec 10 millions d'euros on
n'est pas du tout dans les comptes
il y aura des gens qui sont mis de côté
il y aura des insatisfaits et ceux qui
effectuent des longueurs de cycle 2
12h08 ne seront toujours pas satisfait
donc la colère aujourd'hui et les
reprendre se dirigeait plutôt vers une
colère de la part des nuits 2,6 à en
reste là d'ici la fin août
monsieur non merci d'avoir est en direct
avec mon je rappelle que vous êtes
secrétaire général adjoint du syndicat
optio nuit merci d'avoir été enterré